it goes I'm Reggie one of the cofounders
of penny box I look after product so
everything from ui/ux
engineering code reviews managing the
engineers feature sets testing I'll cut
all that so today I'm gonna give you a
little insight into what I do day in day
out so join me working out of the common
room in the apartment building I'm
staying out here in San Cisco I am going
to be sitting here probably for the next
couple of hours it's a really cool place
there's a really cool common table here
where you see a lot of startup people
unfortunately today there's really no
one around there is a camera crew here
that's actually recording something for
some reason or other but it's nice
facility you got kitchen and there's a
gym actually just over there if you can
see it going there at lunch times and
workouts to clear my mind occasion has a
bit of an insight into some of the tools
of these here at Penny box in the
product development process so tools
like sketch little tracker select the
communications I'm sure a lot of
startups use symbol ones but these are
the ones that we use it works really
well for us and I'm going to run you
through a couple now today very simple
just got my Mac out and obviously the
most important thing coffee I want to
show you first off sketch we sketch for
all of our design UI UX purposes what
I'm going to be doing today is I'm going
to be changing this screen for the next
version of the app so right now the
profile screen for the child it shows
their parents and doesn't really show
much else so this is going into a
version 1 beta release for the next
version what we want to actually show is
a transaction history of what the kid
has actually earned the money for and
what the tasks were so I'm going to go
ahead and change the screen and I'll
show you the final output so what I've
done here now is I've taken a copies of
our board which is the no activity birth
1 and I've replicated over here so I
keep most the elements the same next
thing I've done is added all these on it
so this basically has a scrolling
history of all the tasks and activities
the child has done and this will do for
our purposes and this now goes to the
engineer and they'll be able to
code some of these elements in so we're
gonna have to create some back-end API
calls to be able to handle this sort of
information from our database so that
this is what we've done in circuits
today very handy tool that we use which
is in vision I think many of you would
have come across or heard of envisioned
at least um envision tees were
prototyping so click through screens
that allows you to basically test 50
users how responsive these screens are
or how well the users are responding to
it it's a very handy tool and we
actually use it in collaboration let's
get with a handy plugin that invision
provides called craft so I'll show you
in a second how this works and how easy
it is to upload basically your designs
into envision and start prototyping on
in addition this is envisioned as you
can see we've got the screen that we
were working on it's sketch this is the
original one that we had for the beetle
what I'm going to do is now go into
sketch and over here on the right we've
got a plugin it's a plugin called craft
and it's extremely handy if you're
trying to sync your your artboards from
sketch over to envision it's a very
seamless integration allows you to
basically push all of these as as image
files as PNG Xin to envision otherwise
you'd have to extract each one of these
some manually and operated to a vision
which can take a lot of time so this is
very handy I'm going to go ahead and
upload this new screen that we've done
in to envision I'm going to show you how
it looks on the envision site so this is
the craft plugin that we just opened up
I'll select the artboard I don't want to
sync all of the artboards to envision
right now so I've just selected the
artboard that we want to sync we've
logged in to envision already it's
actually very easy to integrate with
logging to envision I'm going to pick
penny bakhdida which is the the
prototype that we're uploading in
through and selected artboards and seem
to envision right back in now and
envision and as you can see this upload
has been successful and it's come
through into envision so I'm going to
cut throw into it and load known and now
I can go through and create my workflow
to your van which will allow me to
effectively link this up with the
existing prototype and as you click
you'll be able to see the new new
mock-up of the screen that we've done in
sketch so I just want to show you guys
our task management tool we use a tool
called pivotal tracker it's very similar
to zero in that it allows you basically
to create tickets and track tasks we
like it a little bit better than zero we
can do is a little bit too over complex
for what we want to achieve and how one
achieve it so we actually use people
able to do this so just to explain some
the screens here so these are basically
all the tasks had been done to date this
is our current generation and backlog so
these are the tasks that are currently
being done right now
and this is the ice box the ice box is
basically tasks that we've identified
that need to be done and we've
categorized them based on priority so
once the stuff out of the backlog is
done we'll pull these tasks into the
backlog and we'll continue so right now
you can see some accept and rejects here
system maybe engineers some just
recently committed a chunk of code and
what I'm going to do now is pull up a
code I'm going to pull the code out of
bitbucket we use big bucket for our code
repository and I'm going to go through
and do a quick code review pull it onto
my iPhone test device and I'm going to
be able to test some of these on these
engineering tasks have been completed
and then I can either accept them or
reject them as they've been done
according to the criterias that we've
set some code reviewing of some of the
commits that end through overnight what
I'm going to do is I'm going to show you
our bitbucket repository this is where
we store our code ford p box or iOS up
and from there I'm going to pull it out
xcode and load it onto my phone and
protest box so i'm social data so this
is a big bucket account this is where we
basically sync all of our code to so
we've got three repositories here once
for our core API so this is all of our
back-end stuff this is for the front-end
development and this is our gamification
platform that we're developing
alongside so I'm going to go into the
front-end and you'll see that there
isn't too much on the screen but we'll
go to commits and this is where they see
all the commits of conference inside
engineer that's make them commit
so what I'm going to do now is basically
have a look at when you asking it was
done with yesterday's so we're going to
go into Xcode and basically pull this
out so we're gonna check out this code
and we're gonna pull it out of the back
end implementation branch so we've got
separate branches for different levels
of work that we're doing the different
types of code changes that we're making
all additions we're going to pull it
back an implementation I know that's the
one that we need and we're gonna cap it
okay so that's done and this is
basically our code so you're getting a
real preview into how we do all that
Dalton so this is basically all of our
modules what I'm going to do is
basically run this in a release version
and I'm going to connect my my phone to
it really soon but let's just for
demonstrations sake run this on a iphone
6 and it should pop up a simulator so
this is going to be on screen it's not
going to have some of the features that
would like to test for example being
able to use the hardware on a device
that's why it's really important that we
also test alongside the simulator with
real devices so we can see exactly how
it looks how it behaves in our phones
and when you do run on devices you tend
to also catch on some logic bugs or
issues that you wouldn't otherwise see
in a simulator so we always run a
simulator version but alongside that we
also run a real physical device version
as well so the build has succeeded there
and very shortly the simulator will pop
up
so a box is loaded and we comes along
scram so let's just play around and do
this child next I'm going to go through
and test a number of engineering changes
that have happened I won't run you
through all of our code base but this is
basically where all that sits we've got
some pods on different view controllers
there different screens it's all
architected within the Xcode I'm going
to do now is basically create a build of
this current version into the iPhone and
also to the iPad so I can test on these
devices I'm going to do that on Xcode
and push it through as a bill so this
actually circumvent the needs of tests
what if you can now get your way through
Xcode something really handy because you
can monk builds on devices especially
with your development team it's actually
really easy to be able to do those sort
of frequent basis rather than having to
upload to test fly we do you specified
we use it for internal and external
testing with our users and families but
as we're doing development and and to be
able to track through the cycle and as
commits have done so we can take off
from people went arson tickets completed
we just build it directly onto the
iPhone using Xcode a very quick code
review of the changes that were made
um but bucket actually has an extremely
handy section that allows you to look at
the commits and what's been done this
helps me to identify where the
Coachman's have occurred so you can
actually see a side-by-side difference
to see where changes have been made so
the steps are really handy and looking
at this I know exactly which files are
gone to in Xcode and where I'm actually
reviewing the changes that have been
made so this is a review that I've just
completed I'm just about to upload it
onto uploaded build onto my iPhone which
is connected so this is a real device so
it's not a simulator and I'm going to go
ahead and
and create the built all right sir Xcode
is funny but it's about to run it on
penny on on the iPhone and here it is so
penny boxing downloaded so now I can go
ahead and do and complete my testing
which I'm going to go through on both
the iPhone you know and also the iPad in
a very short period of time right for
lunch I'm in the Mission Bay area here
it's access that's a beautiful day today
okay it's got beautiful sunny day today
going through a bit a bit new way which
is really nice you know walk over now to
a cafe near me and have a bit of a bite
to eat and get back to it got back from
lunch and we've got two ladies here from
so bakeable comm doing some work here
today what are you guys cooking up and I
get to taste him off to it's right yeah
at the end of the day I'm working away
and I get nice little sweet surprises
here so Justin what's what
not bad at all it's got the chewy
caramel sent off your arm